welcome everyone to a video on the
together inference API please excuse the
mess I'm in the process of moving to a
ranch to become a farmer at this point
in my AI career there are quite a few
inference apis popping up now and for
any given model you might find that one
API is cheaper than another and as time
goes on the cheapest provider for some
model might also change and you can
interchange cheap with who's the fastest
and so on for me personally I've been
following the team at together for a
while now before I think they were
really even a fully fledged like
company uh and they were just like a
group of people trying to do like
distributed computes and I just really
like what they're doing they're also
quite fast at adding new models and have
a very large selection of text
generation chat image and code specific
models it's also not just about who is
the cheapest it's about who is the
fastest and most reliable at least for
my testing so far I have found the
together API to be extremely fast and
consistent lately I would say it's
faster and more reliable than the open
aai API or the web thing web UI and of
course the question will be asked you
know why API at all don't you have
enough compute to do this yourself or
why not use a cloud host or something
like that because all of the models on
togethers API are open source models one
of the main reasons that I even used the
open AI API was it's just easy to like
quickly try out ideas all of the models
like I said onto together API are
open-source models it's conceivable
maybe one day that won't necessarily
always be the case but right now it is
and you could download and run them
yourself but the together API is just
easier it's convenient and likely faster
than any API you're going to build for
yourself certainly myself
um but still at any point anything that
you build on the together API could be
moved to your own hardware and kept
private internally which is just nice to
know and nice to build on top of okay so
let's check it out to use the API you're
going to need to set up an account and
billing I believe they also give some
credit maybe $20 or something like this
at sign up but depending on when you see
this that might be different once you're
all set up you're going to need to grab
a key which you can find in your
settings by clicking your account logo
at at least at the moment the top right
going to your settings and the API keys
will be there you can feel free to just
place your keys as plain text in your
code but I'm going to use a NV file so I
don't share my key with the world I'll
also be using the together python
package which you can install with Pip
install together I'm also going to be
using some other things like M which
you've got a pip install if you want to
use it as well as colorama which again
pip install if you want to use it to
begin we can do a basic API call and
just make sure everything is working we
can check out how many models are
currently available from the together
API and that's actually three more new
models that uh I got just a few days ago
as I Was preparing this uh and running
this so you can see that they are
consistently adding more and even now
that's a lot of models the hottest
latest model I'd say right now is the
new mistol called mixol which is a 8x7
billion parameter mixture of experts
model we can check out the base model
first now what together is doing is
they're hosting the model and the
inference to that model but before you
get too deep into anything you're going
to always want to acquaint yourself with
the model's prompt structure or prompt
format which might vary between models
alternatively you can also just save
yourself a lot of time in familiarizing
yourself with the model and or even just
writing the code to inference the API by
just using the model in the Together
Playground before you even bother
writing
a character of code so for example we
can head to the Together Playground and
check out some of the models we can then
find mixol click on it and here you can
see the path for that model this is what
you will call for in the API itself you
can also see a link to the hugging face
URL and you can finally open that model
in the playground if anyone from
together is watching I would love to see
the models like prompt
structure on this little thing right
here uh because otherwise I have to go
to the the hugging face link look for
either the prompt structure there or go
to their blog look for The Prompt
structure there like I keep having to
like dig through and like find the promp
structure it'd be wonderful as long as
it's not just purely a text Generation
Um model it'd be wonderful if it uh just
showed me what the prompt structure
ought to be you know so U or or maybe
some examples or something like that
just something that information because
everybody wants it it'd be nice if we
didn't have to go digging but in this
case this is just a purely text
generation model so so we don't actually
have any specific format here let's try
by starting with some text to change the
brakes on your car you start by let's
say you are happy with these results and
you do want this implemented via the API
again the model path is that mistal AI
SL mixol 8 x7b v0.1 and so on uh so we
can use this model with the together API
like
so so that works and just take note that
you can also stream tokens instead of
waiting for the entire response this is
useful if you want to do something like
stream the response to a web browser or
something like that streaming is just
nice for instances where you have
something like a sort of like a chatbot
and the user is directing uh directly
interacting with the AI and where
outputs might be somewhat long and if
you're going to generate let's say
thousands of these tokens it can take
many seconds or even a minute or
something like that but the initial
tokens will begin generating immediately
and there really isn't at least right
now there's no model in the API like
from together that I know of where any
reasonable human could actually read
faster than the rate at which tokens can
be generated so this just helps a ton
with the user experience if you're
writing some sort of app that the you
know direct output from the model will
be read by that user so it can just it
just keeps things kind of uh seamless
okay so those are some pure text
generation examples but there are also
chat or instruct models available
including for Mixr so let's check out
the instruct model even chat and
instruct models are actually just text
generation models but they're trained on
a specific prompt structure to encourage
that sort of structured chat behavior
for convenience so you query them via
the API in actually the exact same way I
will also note that the together models
can be queried via the open AI package
as well and this package abstracts away
a little bit more of the details of text
generation with these like chat or
instruct models so if you're after that
sort of behavior or you've already got
like some underlying software that was
built on open AI but you're just really
hoping to get off you can just swap out
that that like end URL essentially in
that path and still use that package
I'll try to put a link in the
description if I forget and you're
looking for you can't find it uh just
leave a comment and I'll link to that so
for our very first instruct model let's
check out the smaller faster and super
cheap at
0.00002 hopefully I got that right per
1,000 tokens model from together which
was fine-tuned from the GPT JT model
which is trained from the gptj model
from a Luther AI it's kind of crazy how
even AI models themselves are now
layering on top of each other and
abstracting the models themselves so the
model path for this model is together
computer R pajama D Insight 7B instruct
this model is particularly interesting
because I noticed that together actually
has both an instruct and a chat variant
for that red pajama model the chat
variant has a a defined prom defined a
defined prom structure of like human tag
instruction bot tag and then like the
answer and that's the chat variant but
the instruct variant appears to me from
what I can read and tell to be a model
actually trained from just
instructions in general which you will
generally show to the model in the form
of a few shots or at least one shot
examples but the model can still also do
zero shot pretty well and what we mean
by shots are really just examples so
zero shot might be Q colon how many eggs
are in a dozen and then a colon and the
model can look at that just like you you
could look at that and realize like oh
it's looking for an answer and just like
understanding you know get it there's no
historical example shown of the behavior
that you're looking for really but then
if you wanted to show a one-hot example
you might have a you know Q colon how
many days are in a week you have a an
answer of seven and then you'll ask your
real question how many eggs are in a
dozen okay and in this case you're
waiting for that answer from the model
but it's a One-Shot example because
you're actually showing it here's the
kind of behavior we're after
so either way the model should
definitely be able to understand and
follow this pattern obviously this is a
very simple prompt structure most
instruct models could do this with what
we would call zero shot but my
understanding is that the together
Computer red pajama Insight 7B instruct
in particular is trained to just
generally work on instruction-based
prompt structures and work with many
formats whereas generally from what I
have personally seen people
interchangeably use the term instruct
and chat to be actually the exact same
format the exact same prompt structure
most models do not have a chat and an
instruct variant they are the same thing
and used interchangeably well that said
once you begin to work with a format
like this like an instruct or chat
format it can be a little more
challenging to like program and build
that prompt but honestly it's not that
hard so let's see how this might work as
you can see it does answer correctly but
then goes off on something else and then
begins to continue following its own
pattern there and that's kind of weird
for this we can actually make use of the
stop sequences in our case we're
actually confident that the new line or
a new line is the end of the response so
we can actually do something like this
and then finally you could continue to
build on this prompting and account for
a history of back and forth like this
now we've only shown two models out of
120 but hopefully you can already see
some of the power and speed of this
together API it's definitely uh faster
than any anything I could run even
locally but again they're all open
source models and at any point if you
wanted the the privacy or you were
concerned for whatever reason uh or you
need to satisfy like Hippa for you know
healthcare providers in at least in the
United States stuff like that you can
kind of develop out on the API and then
eventually come down local um as needed
another impressive model that I've found
on the together API is the uh find code
llama 34b Python and in this case V1
this is a 34 billion parameter model
trained on python code I've found it to
be quite fast quite accurate very
comparable to what I might get out of
like GPD 4 um the more popular 34b code
model tends to be the wizard LM or
wizard coder python V in this case 1.0
if we're looking at the together API
which um is again like I just said it's
available on that together API both of
these models also have V2s now and
they've shown considerable Improvement
so hint hint at together if yet again
you are watching uh add those uh V2s uh
but this was also uh just playing my
first test with that find model the
thing is each model just to like
basically test it takes you I don't know
at least 15 minutes to download for i
would say most models you need to create
some sort of rudimentary local API
unless you want to rerun it every time
your script breaks or something like
that so you really want something like
hosting the model that you can query
even even if you're just doing it
locally that's generally the best way to
go about it and for me personally I know
I'm not the best and I haven't made this
process like perfectly fast for every
single new model but to test and try any
new model it tends to
take about an hour per model just to set
everything up get everything going
and then start playing with that model
it's too much time such that I'm really
just not willing to test that many new
models out but on together or any other
decent API you can just instantly test
that model either via the API or even
just before that point even just on the
playground just like boom instantly try
it out see how it feels and then try it
on the API and then if you just really
love it and for some reason you still
want to run things locally okay now go
to hugging face now download that model
but even this like these these these 34
billion parameter models for
coding these are 60 to 70 plus gigabytes
in size and pretty slow to run locally I
can test new models on together in
seconds and that's just plain awesome so
at least for me what did I want to do
with that find model I've really long
been trying to find an open source
replacement for chat GPT for the term
GPT project the find 34b model has the
llama to license which basically means
it's open source unless you're a Fang
company and that's awesome uh this is
the basic implementation that I made
with term GPT but with finds code llama
model I try to simplify it as much as
possible there's still quite a few lines
here but the the the end application the
implementation is actually quite simple
and I didn't really want to go through
this like super line by line uh if you
have any questions or if I've glossed
over something uh please feel free to
leave a comment I I'll do my best to
answer any questions but I think it's
pretty straightforward so the prompt
structure of the find model is the
following so you'll start off with this
like pound pound Pound system prompt and
then the actual system prompt what hey
it's me from the future and actually it
turns out that I was mistaken on that
prompt formatting The Prompt formatting
should literally be just for the find a
model an instruction followed by a new
line but even the docs themselves are
kind of confusing on hugging face
because it says in one case it says uh
add a new line colon and then the
example is colon and then space and then
new line and in fact all of these things
really do matter like a space is a token
right so um anyways uh and nothing is uh
to be trusted I suppose anymore but I
will say it's probably something more
like write the instruction colon new
line and that's the proper way to do it
I actually have no idea how I got
confused on this prompt format but
actually that just further makes my case
like I said before I really wish uh
together would just have the prompt
format for any of these chat or instruct
style models I think that would that
would help that would have saved me some
uh trouble but also interestingly enough
using this format that I'm about to show
uh you can totally have great results so
I I this is this is why I'm becoming a
farmer also I did happen to catch that
there is a find code llama V2 which V1
was trained from my understanding
primarily on Python and V2 is trained
with python C++ and a whole bunch of
other things and again for this video
we're using V1 but the next the very
next step is probably use the V2 version
because my guess is that is going to be
far better for you know the project of
term GPT uh than V1 I don't actually
know when together added that may it's
totally possible almost certain I missed
it but maybe that like just got added or
something I don't know from here we can
use the system prompt to set up the
context for the conversation and then I
also just go ahead and show one example
of how I would like the assistant to
interact with user input so in this case
it's a oneshot example so we can use
both a system prompt and a oneshot
example of the behavior that we're after
to really kind of give the model the
impression of what we actually want and
then finally we give one final nudge uh
to the model that we want just bash
commands that's the whole point of term
GPT is it basically structures
everything from question to literal
terminal outputs that could be run if
you so choose to do literally everything
so you don't have to code anything you
don't have to copy and paste anything it
just simply you say what you want the
model produces the results and then
actually runs them via an os. system
call so once we're done building that
that exact prompt um that we're going to
send into the model we actually go ahead
and because again all of these models
are just simply text generation
models it's just some of them are
trained on either instruction types of
formats and then others are trained on a
very specific prompt format but you
don't have to uh like you can inject
whatever whatever history you want to
make up in your mind um and you don't
act like the model is just going to
continue generating information so you
could even find and you will find this
to happen to you that the model if left
to its own desires uh it will actually
continue generating even more future
user inputs for that matter so so you
have to handle for these things so at
least in our case what I'm going to do
is after I get to that assistant answer
I'm actually going to start off the
assistant answer with that like that the
the beginnings of a bash command um just
to really drive home hey you're you're
producing bash commands here so then
using string formatting we can just ask
the user what do they actually want and
then the model should be responding with
a series of those bash commands we can
then use a regular expression to pull a
list of bash commands from that and then
use os. system to execute those commands
running this we get a live visualized
Game of Life in Python which is pretty
cool to see and I actually think this is
a fantastic start to doing this entire
thing with potentially the find model
but also it doesn't have to be just one
model you can use other models to do all
kinds of things like you might come in
with another model maybe one of those
Mistral models to evaluate the output of
the find model and say hey does this
appear to look
like uh output that matches what the
user was looking for for example uh you
could even use another coding model and
then maybe have two coding model
responses and then have another model
that moderates and chooses which one was
best stuff like that you could do all
kinds of combinations here since I
already showed the Bas mix model I feel
like I'd be doing a series disservice if
I didn't show also the mix roll 8X 7B
instruct variant which uh like I said
before most of the time you're going to
see just total um interchangeability
between instruct and chat and I would
say that is the case here this has one
very very specific prompt structure
format that it was trained on that said
just because the model was only trained
on that format does not mean it can't
handle some other custom format you can
almost certainly get away with any
format you want here to to at least some
extent but it's best if you could
structure what you're trying to get done
to this exact format now why might you
want to use the instruct variant over
that base model because they're both
mixol 8 by 7B models so what the heck
why would I do this the reason is the
performance is just simply better for
most of the time if you're trying to use
a model with like user input get some
output the instruct models just tend to
perform much better it's just already on
track to behaving in the way that you're
actually trying to get most of the time
these models to behave the only real
difference here is you need to do prompt
formatting to format your inputs um and
outputs for further inputs uh to that
specific prompt structure and the main
difference here is this model is trained
to follow that very specific prompt
structure which is this like sort of
open string tag and Then followed by
these instruction tags with the
instruction in the middle and then after
those instruction tags you've got the
model and answer and then a closing
string tag and then you can also
continue the context uh by adding more
instruction more string and tags to my
knowledge either there's a
typo or you only have one string open
tag but you have as many string closing
tags as there are prompts now if anybody
has the authoritative answer to this
I've tried looking around this appears
to be the same format structure of like
the llama models and all that they all
seem to say this is the structure you
don't have an open string closed string
for every instruct answer pair uh but if
I'm wrong and and somebody has true
definitive from The Source proof of that
please let me know because this feels
very wrong to me to just have the
opening string and then all the closing
string tags that's just it just doesn't
feel right but but I believe this is the
correct way this this way at least does
work but I just it feels weird and I
feel like it's got to be wrong so
someone please prove me wrong or prove
prove me right I just I I don't know I
still I don't have the for sure answer
on this yet so what I really wanted to
do is rather than just show a single
input in a single response which would
be very simple what I've done is added a
simple way to track the conversation
history a helper function to help build
that history of like pairs of input
response and then finally a function to
build the actual prompt that we will
send to the API and to that model if
there is a history this function will
construct that full history and then
otherwise it just adds the latest input
from the user for the overall prompt uh
to to the model via the API then we just
have a while true Loop to continue doing
this to the user's Hearts content I also
went ahead and increased the maximum
tokens since this model can actually go
out to a context of 32,000 tokens so at
some point to continue context you would
want to probably have some sort of
summarization function again you could
use mixol to literally summarize the
entire context history
um and and do this once tokens get
longer than some number let's say 20,000
so anytime you have your total tokens
that's longer than 20,000 go ahead and
do a summarization and then continue but
anyway this is a good start the rest of
those parameters like uh in the function
like top K temperature top P so on these
are knobs that you can kind of tweak to
adjust the statistical behavior of the
model's token generation but I I just
have been using the settings that are
just default from together in that
playground which I think is a pretty
good start so far uh but also feel free
to Tinker with those uh depending on
what you're after so you can get a lot
of times it can be like a creativity
knob or thought of in in that way um but
every model is going to be a little
different so you'll have to play with
that on your own and again if you really
like this model and for whatever reason
you now you want to run it locally guess
what that model is available on hugging
face you can download that model run it
locally all you want and all the code
that you wrote to work with that build
the prompt for that model everything
everything is literally the same you
would just simply write your own local
API and then you'd query that API the
same way you've been querying the
together API so it's just an incredible
resource um so yeah that's the together
API uh some basics of using it and why
you might use it and finally believe it
or not there's a book you might have
heard of once or twice on my channel
that you might be interested in if
you're looking to learn more about
neural networks and how they work it's
called neural networks from scratch from
myself and Daniel kuwa it teaches
everything from a basic forward pass to
training and optimizing your model and
running your trained models all from
scratch in Python including all of the
math involved and only assumes that you
know basic Python and basic algebra you
can learn more and get yourself a copy
at NN
fs. otherwise I will see you all in
another
video